extreme temperatures very little rain
and intense light plants in the Negev
desert are subject to serious
environmental stress how they cope with
it is one of the main topics of research
here at Israel's blaustein Institute in
sediba care the researchers are also
investigating how desert plants can be
used in agriculture because they're able
to cope with the harsh environmental
conditions
in this experiment the plants get to
enjoy a ride on a carousel each
container can simulate a different
environmental condition
Naftali lazarevich is an expert on
irrigation he and his colleagues
developed this setup right now he's
using it to study bell pepper plants we
want to understand the process of water
flow from the soil into the plant under
certain conditions after we understand
the process we can optimize it and for
instance adjust the irrigation frequency
here at the blaustein institute the
focus is on basic research but
lazarevich knows that it isn't easy to
communicate the results of his work to
farmers that's why he sometimes makes
the hour-and-a-half drive to the Arava
research and development center near the
Dead Sea
from grapes to peppers to millet the
researchers here are investigating
whether plants behave the same way in
real-life conditions as they do in the
laboratory the goal is to produce
research that will directly benefit
farmers today he wants to see how the
date trees are faring but the research
here doesn't only focus on dates grapes
and millet they're also looking at fish
PhD student Tom gloom beds explains that
fish gained biomass quite rapidly and
their excrement can be used as plant
fertilizer any water that's available
can be used and recycled now it's being
cleaned in these barrels
it will then flow next door to the
greenhouse where it's used to water the
lettuce there there's a pipe running
through there that gives oxygen to the
plant roots and the plants grow in the
water take up the nitrate and then the
water without the nitrates and other
nutrients that the plant of course takes
up flows back to the fish so they get
the clean water back again
rice is normally cultivated in areas
that have plenty of water but here the
researchers are testing a drip
irrigation system I'm not saying that we
will grow wise in Israel in the future
but here in this area we have many
volunteers that coming from other
nations and they work here and part of
them are from East Asia and they study
drip irrigation and they will studied it
will we discover with their eyes that
they are familiar with when these
students return home they'll bring what
they learned with them rice can be grown
using much less water also dramatically
cutting nitrogen emissions that damage
the environment